names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about it
the Lombardi tails
don't pay to get too close to anyone in
our line of work they tell you that all
the time you will though we're stupid
like that first time you're in real
danger you should be thinking gosh I'm
in constant threat of my life our
relationship would be a distraction and
not fair to the other person
unfortunately you're made for passing on
your genes first time you're in any real
danger every part of your body every
fiber of your being is gonna say I
almost died commence to having sex this
is because your body's an idiot it
thinks you're still a primitive human in
the Great Rift Valley and the danger it
has in mind is a leopard coming to eat
you so they want you to make a
replacement fast so you're probably
gonna ignore all this advice you're
gonna find someone else maybe a cute
girl you meet downtown or god forbid
another agent you've seen the videos
you've heard the stories you know how we
can end up imagine that's someone you
care about yeah that's fun now the
foundation ain't gonna tell you you
can't have a relationship I represent
that stupid never give an order what
ain't gonna be followed instead they
send you to counseling they hope they
can change your mind hey you know what
they play in the counselors Lobby all
the time Old Yeller
yeah that's the subtlety and understand
that we've come to expect at the
foundation but like I said doesn't do
much good
you're probably gonna do it anyway I'm
just hoping maybe one or two of you is
smart enough to listen the rest of you
though are gonna get busy maybe get
married maybe have kids
best-case scenario the stress of the job
drives you to a divorce
worst case scenario one of you had to
put a bullet into the other one because
it's the kindest thing left I god help
you if you ever fall for a skip
seriously don't do that [ __ ] was I ever
married yeah once her name I don't
remember her name it won't let me I
think she was beautiful